what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with jerry dugan's x-men volume
one and i know we're kind of late to
this honestly after jonathan hickman's
whole in front like his whole just house
and powers of x just his gigantic x-men
run i needed a break from the x-men
comics because it was just so much to
cover as much as i loved the x-men i
needed a break but we are back to it now
and so what this does here this is one
of the coolest things what this does is
it kind of gives us the stories of this
new x-men team now there's a couple
things that we need to run over number
one as you will notice this is part one
and the reason why this is part one is
because this story is told in jerry
dugan fashion it is six issues but a lot
happens especially in the second half
when we start dealing with nightmare and
so what we have to do is kind of split
the difference on this so we'll do part
one today and then probably part two
tomorrow right and then just kind of
slap them together the other thing about
this is that this takes place before the
events of inferno but after the events
of the x-men gala the hellfire gala
because if you guys recall from the
hellfire gala story that we did it was
basically the election of the new x-men
team which is the team that we get here
so what we end up doing here is actually
picking up what is basically with seneca
gardens now seneca gardens is kind of
the place where the x-men have
established what's called the tree house
now we did see that during the uh the
events of like devil's reign and all
that kind of stuff with kingpin like
trying to seize control of new york and
all that kind of stuff this is where
that starts and for those of you guys
who are just coming into the x-men and
aren't really familiar with jonathan
hickman's entire run while we're not
going to run over everything that
happened one of the big things that came
out of it is that with the creation of
krakowa or the x-men's own private
island essentially their own nation that
what they had done is they created these
seeds they basically allowed them to
create portals in different places and
what they've done here with the
treehouse is basically set up a base of
operations in the city of new york now
this is one part the x-men just kind of
expanding out and having more of an
involvement in what goes on in the world
since historically speaking the x-men
have always usually remained isolated
whether it's because they were up in
westchester or they were out on utopia
which is the island off the coast of san
francisco they've always kind of been
removed from society while krakowa
essentially served the same purpose the
establishment of gracoa was to give the
mutant population its own sovereign
nation i guess a kind of jenosha part
two minus all the death and suffering
and then the other part
is them kind of stepping back out into
the world again now one of the things
that goes on here and it's kind of an
undercurrent plot that's not overly
important to what we're going to be
talking about in this particular video
here is basically the death of a person
that seemingly involves the mutant
population it's really been uric who's
investigating it and of course those you
guys who are new ben york is a very
significant member of the marvel
landscape he doesn't have any powers but
he's a reporter in all honesty i always
thought ben yurick's greatest moment
really came during civil war when he was
operating as a reporter on front line
and just kind of like documenting
everything that was going on with civil
war really kind of away from the
superheroes and more of how like the
general society had been impacted by it
so it was kind of an outside looking in
perspective it was really really cool
right again it's not overly important
here but it's literally one of those
moments where because ben uric is so
respected among basically the entirety
of the superhero community he tells
cyclops hey man just because of the
history that we have in terms of the
x-men and really me just the rest of the
superhero community it's important that
i let you know like i'm investigating
the mutants for a murder that happened
but just kind of be aware of that right
and of course cyclops isn't too it isn't
really to divulge a ton of information
but it's just one of those undercurrents
right it's jerry dugan sort of laying
the groundwork for a plot that will
become important later on down the line
now the bigger takeaway from this well
we do get a little bit of exploration
among about the treehouse which is quite
literally a tree house right like the
x-men team lives there they're more of
kind of a field team that operates away
from kokoa uh that what we also end up
getting is basically rogue responding to
what is in effect some object just like
crashing through the sky smashing with
buildings and then ultimately crash
lands when it arrives of course once
rogue sees it it basically looks like a
giant robotic monster right like
what are those things called in uh in in
in japanese anime and all kinds of kaiju
right it looks like a giant kaiju it
literally looks like a kaiju to a degree
right but the thing about it is that
rogue is immediately overcome by this
thing in the sense that like she's hit
by it now one of the things to know is
that rogue doesn't immediately attack
this thing because she doesn't know
what'll happen if it does and in fact
she's told that by jean grey that jean
grey is the de facto leader of this team
and when the rest of the team responds
that's when we kind of get their roster
now we knew the roster from the hellfire
gala storyline but those of you guys who
never read that story or never really
saw the events unfold there which it was
really kind of a launching platform
right it was basically marvelous one of
those stories that marvel writes where
they say like here's a big changing of
the lineup for a lot of the x-men teams
and what the x-men are going to look
like going forward that's basically what
the hellfire gala was but the current
lineup of the team is polaris also known
as the daughter of magneto cyclops of
course jean grey of course x-23 laura
kinney who's referred to as wolverine
now you've also got sunfire and you've
got sync now i'm gonna tell you guys
right now this team while it doesn't
look like it has some of the heaviest
hitters in the entirety of the marvel
universe it's an omega level mutant team
that's exactly what it is sync can copy
the powers of anybody who's around him
now the difference here is that the way
sync used to be back in like the 1990s
generation x and all that kind of stuff
is sync's powers were very very limited
when he was resurrected during jonathan
hickman's x-men run his powers were
expanded and so what this means is he
can duplicate the powers of anybody
around him regardless of whether they're
a mutant or not which means he can copy
the powers of thor whether or not that
makes him worthy of lifting the hammer
of thor i don't know he can copy the
powers of the incredible hulk presumably
to what limit we don't know but he can
copy the powers of anybody the
difference here is that he can only do
it for a limited amount of time it's the
caveat that marvel slapped on sync in
order to prevent him from becoming a
character where he can copy the powers
of anybody that's around him and then
just keep those powers forever because
at that point he would basically become
a godly character he would be like
protege from the old guardians of the
galaxy comics back in the 1990s right
like 1980s whenever it was he'd become a
character like that where he could
duplicate the powers of anybody with no
upper limit but that's the kicker we
don't know how far reaching his powers
go but we'll actually find out in this
story which is gonna be one of the
coolest things we're gonna find out just
how strong he can get and i'm gonna tell
you right now this guy is broken right
like sync is so broken of course sunfire
is also a very heavy hitter new readers
of marvel comics probably don't know
about sun fire he is comparable to
johnny storm of the fantastic four his
ability to manipulate fire when it comes
to his character what's really
interesting is depending on what era
you're reading like if you read the old
chris claremont stories he can be as
powerful as johnny storm right become as
hot as the sun in more modern iterations
his powers have kind of been toned down
so he really waxes and wanes based on
who's writing the stories jerry dugan is
going to return him to the classic
sunfire that we know from marvel comics
but he's just ridiculously powerful now
when this team shows up here seeing this
thing for what it is the first thing
that happens is polaris responds and
tries to manipulate it believing that
it's metal but if it is metal it's no
metal that she can recognize now one of
the things to remember is that polaris
ability to manipulate metal is not
limited to whatever metal she recognizes
right so it's not like if she's never
encountered vibranium she can't
manipulate vibranium no if it is a metal
she can control it which indicates this
thing is not made of metal right that
it's not an actual metallic being it's
just an exceedingly hard material so of
course she's rescued by rogue because
she almost dies
[Laughter]
right she almost gets destroyed and so
while this thing is going nuts and
attacking the city of new york what it
does is it lets off this kind of psychic
pulse that literally starts affecting
the minds of everybody around it and
giving them all migraines the only way
they can block this from happening is by
polaris using the construction metals of
different sites around her to encase
them in steel and then in turn jean grey
use her powers to basically protect
everybody now one of the things to know
and it's very it's incredibly easy to
overlook here is that jerry dugan is
hugely amplifying jean grey he's taking
a page out of chris claremont and the
reason why is that if you read the old
x-men comics which i don't know anybody
in the modern era who did people will
say they have but like i don't think
very many people have if you ever went
through the old x-men comics by by
stanley and jack kirby which i had to do
that if for no other reason than to make
videos like x-men explained and at least
know what i'm talking about plus they're
my favorite team of all time so i just
did it of my own interests right but if
you if you're going to read the old
stories jean grey was helpless right she
was really a useless member of the team
chris claremont changed that by
launching the phoenix and the dark
phoenix sagas and then intended to kill
her off now she did become a part of
like x-men gold x-men blue you had x
factor where she was a member of that
team and so on and so forth what's been
happening in more recent years under
jonathan hickman and even a little bit
before him when he went into like the
original x-men red run and different
things like that is you got this sort of
rise of gene gray yet again and you
really see it here where she's being
elevated to more of a high level
leadership position than anything else
this was especially prominent when she
was on the quiet council for a time
right so it was a really cool thing to
have in terms of her character being
elevated from just like a legacy member
of the x-men who's around and does stuff
when she's not being killed right it's
cool to see her being moved into this
position now gene can only hold this for
so long but sync ends up coming up with
a plan the plan of course is shared
telepathically with everybody else but
it's to essentially use well at least to
use a combination of materials and so on
and it's kind of a strange plan that you
wouldn't normally see from the x-men and
honestly without sync they wouldn't have
been able to pull it off and so what is
up going on is by using all these
different you know really using the
powers of polaris all this machinery the
powers of gene and so on and so forth
what they basically end up doing it's
constructing a megazord like a giant
nanny robot from like the old chris
claremont x-men comics who somehow has
managed to continue existing and i don't
know why it's there but they literally
construct a giant robot
which is amazing i absolutely love this
i love that they created a robot to
fight a giant robot so it's basically a
battle of like a jaeger versus a kaiju
right this story turned into pacific rim
and i absolutely love it
i think it's amazing but literally this
thing has like the powers of cyclops
like it just blasts out optic blast
using the power of cyclops it's pretty
capable now the funny thing here is of
course they're able to overcome this
thing right because it's basically using
all the different powers of the x-men in
unison so it can use the powers of
cyclops to fire optic blast it can use
the power of sunfire to literally shoot
fire and initially they kind of you know
it kind of seems to get the upper hand
to a degree but what the machine ends up
doing is it launches a fastball special
now for those of you guys who don't know
about that the fastball special is a
classic move and really a hallmark of
the wolverine mythos that it's a move
that's performed by colossus throwing
wolverine at something and so basically
it's this robot throwing laura kinney at
this kaiju monster right and like
literally laura kenny just kind of
invades it starts slashing at it and
tearing little pieces of it up and so on
and so forth but basically killing it
from the inside out and the funny thing
is that while the x-men are defeating
this the avengers in the fantastic four
are just now arriving on the scene so
again this is one of the big changes
that we have going on here in this
mythos which is the x-men are playing a
more prominent role in the superhero
community and it's really jerry dugan
actually saying in a lot of ways the
x-men are more capable than the avengers
or the fantastic fork and the reality is
that they are some of the most powerful
beings that exist in all of marvel
comics are mutants because they're power
because they were designed that way
right i mean when stanley and jack kirby
and them created the avengers in the
fantastic four their powers were based
on practical application peter parker
receives a bite from a radioactive
spider the fantastic four going to space
they're blasted with cosmic rays back
when those characters were being created
the desire was to create characters that
were more realistic and they would get
their powers in a way that was more in
line with like the atomic age as it
existed in the 1960s and 1970s to a
degree by the time the x-men came along
at least following the initial failure
with stanley and jack kirby to like make
them compelling when chris claremont
came around their powers were just
limited to your imagination right so
literally you had characters that could
alter reality you had characters that
could tap into other dimensions they
could teleport from one place to another
there's no limit so the most powerful
beings in existence are mutants for the
most part what this does is it shifts
over to why this happened in the first
place and what we end up doing is
picking up at a place called game world
which is as it's described where the
worst people in the universe come to
have the best time and it's a cool place
because it's actually orbited by two
black holes or at least two black holes
that are harnessed and their energy is
utilized which is something that happens
in marvel comics black holes they do
exist they're every bit as powerful as
you're used to them being right in the
sense like their gravity is essentially
infinite right it exceeds that of the
speed of light and that nothing can
basically escape so you can drop
somebody into a gravity well but if you
stay far enough away from the event
horizon of a black hole far enough away
from its gravitational pull that you
won't be sucked in you can use time
dilation of gra of black holes to
manipulate time and that's what happens
here right like a single night on game
world is a month everywhere else time
just passes slower so and the reason why
this happens is because game world is
basically a place of gambling right that
what happens is people literally just
gamble anything and everything in this
particular instance you have a guy named
cordyceps jones who has a crazy name and
in fact this is not the first appearance
of his character cordyceps jones
originally appeared in rocket volume
what was it rocket volume one in issue
number four i think back in 2017.
essentially what happened here is it was
a heist story with rocket and deadpool
they basically like deadpool absorbed
cordyceps jones
and because cordyceps jones could not
control deadpool due to his healing
factor they used cordyceps jones
brainwaves to essentially empty his bank
account they robbed the guy and then
deadpool spit his spores out into a
gutter and then cordyceps jones swore
vengeance and that was basically it ah
this is one of those guys where he's
introduced and then in like 10 years
somebody's gonna write a story somewhere
where he's just gonna be this
ridiculously op character but at this
moment he's basically running game world
and that's what we end up finding out
that what's happening here is game world
basically sees or at least all these
people see earth the same way they
always have which is just kind of a
parasite an issue on the planet and what
they desire to do is basically wipe out
all humans on earth and then basically
take earth for itself and so instead of
just launching a traditional like
invasion right like decrees show up or
the scrolls show up or operation
galactic storm or something along those
lines that what they're doing is they're
actually taking bets on who will be the
most successful in annihilating earth
and this is when you get into one of the
coolest things ever because what ends up
happening is that this this being right
[ __ ] you of the new mari actually ends
up bringing forth a wager that this
person holding this vial will basically
sacrifice themselves but that their
wager is they can be the ones to
annihilate all humans on earth and that
if they win then of course this guy
who's sacrificing himself his family
will be well compensated which seems to
happen regardless but they'll also walk
away with everybody's winnings right
like with all this money and so what
this guy does is basically teleport or
transport to earth and when he crash
lands and he arrives he uncorks the
container he drinks the liquid inside
and then unleashes the annihilation wave
now let me tell you guys something man
like if you guys ever read the initial
uh the original annihilation story that
that story was crazy right annihilation
took place during the events of civil
war and we covered it right civil war
was based that was like on earth right
like the superheroes are fighting over
registration annihilation was annihilus
leading an army of essentially bugs
across the universe and conquering
virtually everything galactus was
captured the silver surfer was almost
killed right like all these things
happened like the universe almost
collapsed quite literally the story
opens up with richard ryder nova and
peter quill's star-lord just leading a
refugee force fleeing for their lives
that's literally how the story opens
[Laughter]
right like it's absolutely crazy and
here's the superheroes on earth fighting
over government legislation right it's
the most human thing ever but
nonetheless right the point that i'm
making here is that this annihilation
wave arriving on earth while it
initially starts off small that's the
beauty of the wave the more it consumes
the bigger it gets and that's exactly
what happens here now one of the things
i also want to specify the x-men have no
experience with the annihilation wave
it's one of the things that's very easy
to forget we've only seen the
annihilation wave twice the first time
was during the original annihilation
story which the x-men were not a part of
and the second time was during john and
hickman's avengers new avengers oh my
god when captain america ordered the
release of the annihilation wave to be
used against the builders as a last
ditch offense otherwise they would have
all died right they would have lost to
the builders themselves that's the only
time we've ever seen the annihilation
wave in marvel the x-men were never a
part of that the only reason and it's
one of those cool things is basically
explained here the only reason the x-men
are even aware of the annihilation wave
is because when the avengers unity squad
was formed so a combination of the
avengers and the x-men operating as a
singular team so like uncanny avengers
captain america made the x-men members
of that team watch stories about the
annihilation wave so they could learn
about extinction level events because
that's what the annihilation wave is
right like none of the other superheroes
on earth know the annihilation wave is
here and so because they don't know that
by the time they do become aware of it
it's game over right like there's no
saving the world it's the annihilation
wave is one of the most powerful forces
that's out there it's just it's insane
right so what ends up happening of
course is the x-men respawn and they end
up facing off against the annihilation
wave as best they can but the cool thing
about this is they also have sun's uh
sunfire and sunfire of course
controlling fire this is really jerry
dugan building off jonathan hickman's
fantastic four actually i'm sorry that's
the third time we saw the annihilation
wave was during jonathan hickman's
fantastic four i know somebody's already
commenting somebody already put a
comment down there that was like nerp
nerf nope rob actually derp de derp uh
the fantastic fours when they appeared
as well when johnny storm turned around
in the most epic moment ever when he was
locked in the negative zone and he's
like flame on and took on the entirety
of the annihilation wave by himself god
i hope we get to see that moment in the
mcu but unless right like that's the
third time that we saw it so i know for
a fact somebody's gonna leave that
comment here's what we're gonna do find
a comment like that the comment that
says nope they also appeared in the
fantastic four that was the third time
they showed up the comment that says
that that gets the most likes will get a
rob core ring from me ignore the people
that are telling you get ps5 this is a
scam it's bots youtube doesn't care
enough to fix it but with with this like
i'm telling you now that comment that
gets the most likes i will give you a
rob core ring i will find some way for
us to contact each other and i'll give
you a rob query so here's the thing
right with this whole with the the group
showing up here when it comes to these
guys sunfire could annihilate the
annihilation wave very very fast given
the nature of his powers and how capable
he is but they don't do it right off the
bat and the reason why is because while
they're there jean grey picks up on a
beacon of one of the bugs or a being
who's there and is like something's
different here right like there's
something here that's different now of
course she's picking up on what's left
of the brain signals of the being that
initially released the annihilation wave
on earth in the first place and so what
this is really is just simply really
sunfire providing some measure of
protection sync using the powers of
various x-men to ensure the safety of
gene and polaris when they actually go
inside of the annihilation horde in
order to tap into the mental
capabilities of this being and find out
what's going on jean grey only gets a
kind of quick mental glimpse right she
gets a quick momentary glimpse which is
of game world she doesn't know what it
means she doesn't know the significance
of it she just gets this small momentary
glimpse seeing a black hole it initially
leads her to believe that it has
something to do with orcus but that's
when she tells sunfire okay i've got
what i need torch everything and sunfire
does exactly that right he obliterates
everything and so with all those with
the entirety of the annihilation wave
destroyed that what this does is it
leads to the x-men asking questions okay
so obviously there's a much bigger thing
here right there's something called game
world right now that jean grey's
actually had time to settle on the
information but what ends up happening
here is that before gene and them are
able to fully understand everything
that's going on they're immediately met
by the arrival of the high evolutionary
now here's the thing right herbert
windham is still probably one of the
greatest villains in all of marvel
comics i'm a little worried about how
they're going to treat him in guardians
3. i'm a little concerned about how he's
gonna he looked a little wonky at the
san diego comic-con panel i'm not gonna
lie the important thing here is the high
evolutionary is one of the most powerful
beings that exists out there in marvel
comics right like the evolutionary war
and all that kind of stuff this guy's
capable he can do a lot he started out
as a normal guy but then just started
fast tracking his own evolution and made
himself as powerful as he is now when he
shows up here it's also a gamble right
he shows up here on behalf of game world
and is like okay so here's what's
happening x-men humanity has basically
screwed up its world right environmental
catastrophe and different things like
that so here's what i'm offering i am
offering you the ability to spare spare
humanity the coming decades of just
starvation as they literally become
climate refugees right they move from
one part of the earth to another trying
to escape the climate crisis they've
created for themselves you can we can
literally just annihilate them right now
and call it a day right like we can give
them a merciful death or you can let
them just labor into the coming decades
and die a slow death which one do you
prefer here and the x-men are like we're
not going to annihilate all of humanity
right now even though it is kind of the
smarter thing to do because basically
like we're past the point of saving
anything right like all we can do is
just not die as fast right that's like
not go extinct as fast i'm not even
joking like that's kind of where we are
right now when it comes to the climate
crisis here in the real world but it's
also one of those things where they're
also like we're we're part of a
preservation of life right we're not
going to just annihilate humanity in its
entirety so what the high evolutionary
does is he presents his daughter
luminous now luminous has been around
for a little while right she's not new
here right she's been around marvel
comics for a little bit in fact she's
been around since 2015. we know the
nature of her powers in the sense that
she's basically the result of the high
evolutionary combining the genes of
quicksilver and the scarlet witch into a
singular being which does allow her the
ability to manipulate uh chaos magic so
it makes her incredibly capable but what
it also does here is it presents the
scenario where the high
is like i could just wipe you all out
right now if i wanted to and so that's
when rogue basically like jumps in and
attacks the high evolutionary and so
with that happening like a fight breaks
out between all of these guys the high
evolutionary and his daughter and the
x-men and so on now this is when we get
the moment where we find out just how
powerful sync is that as this fight is
going on it's really them just kind of
pairing off right technically it's most
of the x-men facing off against uh the
high evolutionary's evolutionary guard
which is kind of like his own his own
his own force so those are the guys who
are familiar with the villain apocalypse
this is comparable to apocalypse's four
horsemen of death right that kind of a
thing right his own henchmen essentially
or magneto's brotherhood of evil mutants
i mean take your pick right it's his
henchman essentially but where this
thing goes on of course there's an
effort to ensure that this kind of bomb
doesn't go off right this annihilation
bomb doesn't go off and take out the
entirety of humanity but sun fire and
sync actually sync up their powers where
sync basically duplicates the powers of
sunfire and then immediately attack the
high evolutionary and where they are
initially able to overcome him because
of just his insane healing factor which
i would argue exceeds that of wolverine
and is comparable to deadpool that of
course he's able to overcome both of
them but then when he sees a sink he
realizes okay like i thought that like
rogue's ability to duplicate the powers
of others was capable no you are way
beyond the character of rogue right you
are way beyond her powers and so of
course sun fire is taken out sink of
course rescues sunfire and then he takes
off and then in realizing what's going
on he immediately attacks luminous and
then he overcomes her and in doing so
seizes control of her powers and that's
when he tells the high evolutionary i've
taken the powers of your daughter and
with these powers i can do like i know
exactly what she's capable of i can do
whatever i need to do that's the thing
here luminous is able to tap into chaos
magic she can in effect do everything
the scarlet witch can do which means
sync can do the exact same thing to this
point right now this is the highest
level of power we've seen sync attain
the powers of the scarlet witch the
ability to tap into chaos magic to alter
reality with no defined upper limit this
guy has just achieved godhood like that
in an instant right in an instant this
guy is just beyond everybody on earth
like literally every single being that
exists out there in the entirety of
marvel comics say for the highest level
cosmic entities this guy has just just
surpassed them all franklin richards
like every single one of them he's
beyond all of them that's literally
where this guy is and the ironic thing
about this and what's so funny about
this is the high evolutionary is like
well done right i'm glad to see that you
were able to duplicate the powers of my
daughter it's impressive to see what
you're capable of and where sync is like
this is not an empty threat the reality
of the high evolution area is like but
here's the thing though do you really
think that i would create someone like
my daughter who had the ability to
manipulate such vast levels of energy
and power without creating some kind of
a kill switch and he shuts off the
powers of sync right now he's not really
all of sync's powers it's the powers of
his daughter and so sync is just right
back where he was before it's a really
really cool moment but this is the thing
this is not jerry dugan elevating the
powers of sync and saying now he's god
this is jerry dugan saying hey you guys
want to see how powerful sync can be
here you go right that's what he's doing
it's him basically saying this is a new
level of power that he can attain so now
we know he can copy the powers of
anybody who can alter reality on a
universal scale so the question now
becomes how much more powerful can he
get and so really the high evolutionary
response by simply saying okay uh i will
leave here i will take my folks and i
will walk away but only under one
circumstance that sync gives me a it
gives me a drop of his blood now this is
the high evolutionary saying you're the
most significant person here i've never
met you before never encountered you
before but you have my interest this is
a dangerous thing and in fact sink even
asked that question like once high
evolutionary departs and leaves the
question of sync is like did i make a
mistake right and and cyclops and jean
grey are like no like you saved
everybody's life here and that's the
most important thing and things like so
what if like giving the higher
evolutionary my blood comes back to
haunt us and cyclops was like oh i keep
forgetting man this is your first run
around with a high evolutionary no it's
gonna come back and bite us in the ass
that's the way it always works with the
high evolutionary he always he always
shows up to gain a particular thing it
could be something as small as your drop
of blood or could be something much much
bigger but he'll come back and like
he'll probably create something based
off of you so yeah i mean it's
definitely going to turn out to be a
terrible decision right that's just kind
of how that goes but at the end of the
day it's the nature of things so with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to again again you know
there's a lot that's happened here this
actually switches over to a story that
involves nightmare for a little bit and
ultimately switches back so with that
being said we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you